what's up everyone welcome to the
colliders Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water this is my very first
interview of Sundance 2023 and I'm so
excited to be kicking it off with the
team behind birth rebirth
oh my God you're moving these are the
kind of big swings and themes and other
elements of the movie that we're going
to get into that I really love to talk
about and explore but right now a lot of
people out there won't know what your
movie is about I'm gonna have to give
you these duties you're gonna do this a
lot while you're here can you give
everyone a brief synopsis of birth
rebirth
um it's a Frankenstein inspired uh story
about motherhood
um and grief I think and uh co-parenting
a reanimated child
job well done and there's there's so
many things to explore within that
though
um first feature here it's a really big
deal to select the right story for your
first feature so why did this particular
idea and these themes feel like they
paired well for you to take that plunge
with
this idea has been sort of in my mind in
one form or another since I was like 13
and I first read Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein so it wasn't actually the
first feature that I that I wrote and uh
but it's been sort of gestating for the
longest time um so to speak and it's
it's definitely I feel like every phase
of my life where I've come back to it
it's been infused with sort of the the
fears and anxieties of that phase
um and this felt like the moment for it
to all come out I have so many
follow-ups first if you've been thinking
about it for that long what would you
say is the biggest difference between
how you first pictured the film when you
first envisioned it in full and what we
see in the final feature now well
there's a lot of
um you know I think we've described it
as sort of the horror of having a body
um you know there's there's that it's
body horror but in a sort of different
way
um and I you know I was literally going
through puberty when I started thinking
about Frankenstein and a female Dr
Frankenstein and using the processes of
her body to create something with her
mind so that was really at the Forefront
of of the project when I started
thinking about it and then you know when
I was in my mid-30s and it was really
coming to fruition
everyone in my life was talking about
Parenthood you know having a child with
your body having a child another way
choosing not to have a child that choice
being made for you it was just it was
just on I mean my mind but everybody's
mind and my life and so it really became
a core part of the film
all right so now for my cast here again
this is a first feature you are all very
busy and I imagine it can feel like you
know a bit of a risk to jump in with a
first time feature filmmaker and know
that they're the right person to helm
the project so why did Laura feel like
one the right Helmer for this particular
story but also like a potentially good
collaborator for the way the three of
you like to work
[Music]
um you know I had a very long Zoom with
Laura I don't know if you were aware of
the pandemic that we are still going
through it but um that was when we met
was on a very long zoom and I think one
of the things that emerged during that
time was sometimes the vulnerability was
uh right on the surface so I feel like
we bonded immediately and I remember
actually right after that meeting saying
like I don't know if you want me to do
this thing I love it but I feel like
we're friends forever at the very least
because we really had a had a deep bond
during that moment and the other thing I
would say is I watched everything that
Laura made that I could get my hands on
and it all blew me away so that was for
me I I felt like I could trust them with
my life like especially something this
complicated and this kind of unique
tonally besides the fact that it was
just written I mean a spectacular script
besides that I felt like once I saw the
these pieces Friday was incredible porn
without sex
truly amazing have you seen that oh my
God my porn porn without sex it's the
best thing so sad that actually might
have been the real Clincher Friday is
spectacular but porn without sex I was
like there we are there there it is yeah
but no I was like this this person knows
exactly what they're doing and uh and
also just they're fun
funny great it's just felt like warm all
the right keywords right there
she said warm
um I I don't think I might
experience was as deep as yours
um I got a call from my reps and said um
there's a script that the uh the writer
director wrote with you in mind I was
like what
so my ego clicked
and then I read it and I was like wow
this is amazing I read it a few times
um
um okay you know our circumstances are
minimal and risky especially as women in
film so I was like I want to do it I
want to do it and you know we all agreed
that it was powerful I had my husband
read it
um and there was so much in it to do
that I think as artists you don't often
get to do in one project you know so
much to explore so much so much to risk
so much to regret you know even when you
watch it you get consumed with your work
and but uh uh then you get distracted by
how good everybody else is and that's
the best film to be a part of
this was a very Kismet I mean I I talked
about it last night a little bit but um
I feel like I was in my kitchen
breastfeeding my child and I looked down
at my beautiful darling child's face and
was like I wonder if she would just like
bite down right now
and I was like
I had no teeth but there was something
horrifying about the moment and the the
process of motherhood vacillates wildly
between body horror and extreme elated
like like Cosmic appreciation for life
and I felt like this overwhelming
feeling that
our film Cannon does not
have movies that talk about this
experience and you know spoiler alert we
all come into the world through this
path
um or out this path
um and so I was just overwhelmed with
the feeling of like
missing all the women from the 70s who
would have made crazy weird psychotic
batshit stuff about pregnancy birth
making life forming life and then the
horror of keeping that life alive
keeping a baby alive is absolutely
frightening and so you know I had been
through death before that and so death
is frightening but this was like I was
like why why isn't there like 50 100
movies like this should be a main topic
of films you know of women giving birth
and then all of a sudden I get Laura's
I got Laura's script and I'm like oh
here it is oh my God like ask and you
shall receive and I was couldn't have
been more excited about
participating in this film being a part
of it supporting it being here at
Sundance and supporting it it's the
perfect place for it and it's just this
like
I'm like oh man if I could watch like 10
more her I'm like where's the Marvel
horror movie about
give it to Laura mark
I would watch that too right yet again
many follow-up I'm not even going to any
of the planned questions I had and I'm
going to be rushing to squeeze
everything in in the end
um Judy just brought up the idea that
this role was written for you can you
both speak a little bit to writing a
role for an actor then finally getting
the opportunity to give that role to the
actor and then maybe how that role
changed at that point
oh yeah it was terrifying um you know I
I was I'm a big fan of duties for a long
long time
um I actually saw a film that played a
Sundance I believe Gun Hill Road
um in which she was incredible and it
was around the time that this script was
coalescing that I saw the film and I was
just like that Sealy oh my God that's
silly um and every subsequent draft I
just had Judy in mind so then when I was
getting on a zoom with Judy I was like I
don't don't screw it up oh my gosh you
know it's very very intense I was like
be normal it was it was but you know we
sort of immediately bonded and uh yeah I
mean you brought everything I thought
you would to the role and then just more
it just I to me watching you it felt
like a glove
um and it was a real pleasure
I I felt the same way I was terrified uh
you always I I think for me as an actor
I always want to know what the right
questions to ask are I always want to go
past that certain place like you know
and instead of just kind of like letting
it uh fall into place which is exactly
what she did um so flattered and under
pressure for being the person in mind
for the film and yet
um feeling the fit when you read it is a
true a true gift and we were able to
explore and discuss and try different
things
um uh uh that were rewarding it is uh
Laura built an environment that we will
not stop talking about
um how it all begins behind the camera
um and the only reason we're all for
here is because it has to it's a film
made by and for women and in front of
the camera with women we had like uh uh
about let's say 75 women on the set
queer diverse and um that's fits like a
glove you feel safe you feel comfortable
um you don't feel well you do feel
nervous about uh complaining about
something that's not working for you but
you know that you're doing it for the
film for the role because it means
something to you and because you're
representing that for everybody who's
around and that's why like a lot of the
crews showed up yesterday which is
completely rewarding you know and uh and
and you just feel like yeah you want to
see what you are a part of that there's
no way in one way there's one way or
another is going to be rewarding to you
as an artist I want to keep you guys
here forever can you give me an example
of a time when you didn't necessarily I
mean not I don't want to use the word
complain but you raised a concern about
something it was heard and something
changed for the better immediately and
it was a behind the scenes issue
um with housing and stuff or
accommodating on a day where it was
emotionally taxing
so um but that's a position of
leadership I think that you have to take
in order for uh because what have if you
what my experience and over 20 years of
TV and some film
um you you sit on it and then you spend
days bitching about something that you
could have at least said something about
and you do it for the benefit of your
performance first and for the benefit of
what they're trying to realize for you
in the film instead of walking around uh
on um inappropriately grateful for being
there when you're there to become a part
of it
it's also something I think as women in
this business I also feel like sometimes
I hesitate in different atmospheres
especially when it's primarily a male
dominated atmosphere because I worry
that I'll be perceived a certain way as
a woman complaining so it makes a
difference the atmosphere that you're in
when you feel like you'll be heard build
um building on the idea of the
importance of the crew that you've
assembled here I'll preface this by
saying everybody involved in the making
of This film is very important but I do
like asking this just so we could learn
more names of artists that we aren't
necessarily you know seeing in front of
a camera as often but can each of you
name one behind the scenes unsung hero
that changed your experience on this
movie for the better that you want our
audience to know about
RDP
uh yeah
um last night the weird thing about
participating as an actor in a project
is like there's so much that happens
after we leave and onset you you can
look like at dailies and you can sort of
see the screen sometimes you can see
what's going on but she I was blown away
last night I mean the
attention to detail she'd had some shots
in this movie that like uh there's a
shot where your eye is lit like it's
glowing one eye and I was like this is
so weird and like I've never seen that
on film and she like like literally like
backlit your eyeball which I don't even
understand how that's done and I'll tell
you when we were looking at your your oh
I can't tell you you're the the thing
the thing in the yeah uh and I I saw my
staring at it and my reflection in it oh
wow and I didn't I never really noticed
that before and it was just like a
brilliant detail and because you know of
our limited accommodations I'm sorry to
cut you off but you know
um uh uh ajaya had to get really really
creative with and and it was such an
intimately shot film and so fun so fast
I don't know how she did all the I mean
you I did it as well it wasn't just like
you know but yeah those kind of shots
were assembled so quickly I can I the
first thing because the andahar twins I
feel like I think of them as a band now
I'm like the andahar twins but
production designers Courtney and
Hillary andahar are in the special
effects can we talk
I'm obsessed with body horror special
effects Gore my God a plus all around
Lisa forced is Lisa forced was our
special effects prosthetic makeup artist
and she is a
wizard I mean just everything was
incredibly grounded medically and
Incredibly realistic and yeah she did
amazing it's just a little bit odd
because this person might not but maybe
this person will go on to have a career
in film I don't know but our medical
consultant Emily Ryan MD we call her
Emily medical
um I feel like I hope she she was like
as much apart for me of this movie as as
the three of you I mean and she's
extraordinary she's a Stanford
pathologist that took a few months off
to basically advise on our film um and
she's actually been working on the
script with me for years she's uh
College roommates and best friends with
my composer Ariel marks who was the
person I was going to name who is who is
unreal I've been working with her since
since my movie Friday forever
um but she literally built with me like
with my voice a sound library of synths
to create the score for the film I read
that and my brain cannot compute how how
someone comes up with that idea and how
it actually works and happens she
actually yeah recorded you tell they
didn't know oh yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm
the I'm the I'm this Orchestra
oh my gosh I'm so impressed right really
yeah Ariel is amazing yeah I wanted to
um create some really unique synth
sounds and we couldn't quite find in
libraries existing libraries what we
wanted so she actually recorded me my
mother
um a three-year-old the daughter of our
sound mixer Joe riglieri uh who didn't
who didn't quite make it in but we we
were experimenting with all kinds Emily
said are you also at some point in the
soundtrack like reading something about
preeclampsia Oh I thought we tried that
I don't think
no and then and the sound was uh
gripping and that's the kind of thing
that sound things like Sound and Music
sneak in or they stick out and and it
does both you know and you remember it
and it's powerful you have to wind down
with you guys soon I'm gonna try to
squeeze in two more questions see what
is as fun as we are I want I would
happily keep you here forever if I was
allowed someone will yell at me behind
the camera bringing up the idea of
working with a medical specialist for uh
so many years I'm curious what is
something about her expertise that
changed something in the script in a way
that surprised you something that you
didn't realize was going to be like the
truth of our reality but she corrected
it and now we can see in the film
well I mean so much and I was actually
wanted like an hour-long tutoring
session from Emily before the Press day
which I didn't get which is like remind
me of all the medical things
um but I mean the rose developing her
her life-giving serum from stem cells uh
is absolutely rooted in in regenerative
medicine Trends today
um I definitely wrote the line Rose has
the complicated serum apparatus on her
windowsill and was like someone will
figure that out and it was amazing
because actually the andahar Twins and
Emily medical
um not only that sounds like a band I
know right I like the best band not only
designed this incredible apparatus but
it it like works I mean you know she was
just like describing to me the
functionality of how things are
distilled and and and changed throughout
that process
um and so yeah I think that was
mind-blowing to me that that they could
make that real discovered the cure for
death yeah this is a really funny thing
but you know there was a scene when I'm
like looking the microscope and looking
at a thing and I was like what else
would I be should I be writing something
down Emily like I don't know what people
do would I be typing it right she goes
like well what you're doing I would just
be making like hash marks and I was like
I can totally do that convincingly I
know how to do that and I was thinking I
was like just hash marks is that
scientific at all
it sounds crazies yeah that's a silly
thing though but I was like my mind is
blown all right you're bringing up a
silly thing gives me an excuse to ask my
last question this is very silly it
might crash and burn but just for fun
all four of you real you not your
character you are forced to reanimate
someone or something you can't raise
that monster by yourself who in your
life do you team up with to co-parent
your Frankenstein's monster
I could do this pretty quickly because
it would be my co-writer uh Brendan
O'Brien um we we pretty much did it
together so that's fair yeah yeah we we
have a long history together and uh yeah
it's a boring answer but it's it's my
answer
my first thought was my my best friend
since I was a child but then actually as
soon as you moved on further I was like
It's gotta be Judy
I'm sorry yeah I'm sorry but I trust you
in scary situations with weird children
not that AJ was weird I'm talking about
the character
um
I'm going to I would reanimate my my dog
just like we reanimated the pig and I
would use my kid because you know they'd
be all down
you know they'd be like yeah let's do it
and we do it like they did it in the
movie
um
and it's a whole family family it's
birthday birthday series limited series
because we're too cool for that first
first rebirth
that'd be cool
I'm too fancy yeah the ghost
s oh
um
I mean this is like so obvious but who
would I reanimate yeah oh I didn't pose
that question but if they want to know
the answer I'm fine with it I'm like I
can't I don't know if I don't know if I
can
oh really oh
no I mean I probably wouldn't reanimate
a pet I feel like the question of the
reanimation is like a morality question
that I've probably never I'm like you
have to let the sleeping pigs lie this
is why I asked for the partner in crime
instead
I feel like a huge part of the movie is
like death comes for you and maybe it
should it's a really creepy thing about
the film that's the rebirth part we say
why yeah like who would you but what if
like what if like me and Judy reanimated
things and then you had to we were like
you're it's in you're in charge I had a
baby in the middle of the pandemic
and my mom and my partner this is such
an obvious answer basically like felt
like we already went through some sort
of like
um
blank weird sci-fi experience like my
mom I think had like like drove out with
like a Shewee so she wouldn't stop at
restrooms she would just like pee on the
side of the road like it was like like
stopping at like I mean it was like we
are in
World War II bread lines trying to get
like vaccines it like it was wild and so
I feel like if you really needed to
reanimate somebody the morality question
would come with those two those are my
ride or dies you kind of you kind of
can't separate the two but I only ask
questions that I can come up with an
answer to and I couldn't come up with an
answer like would I actually do it but I
know the people I would turn to if it
was forced upon me yeah yeah
thank you for bringing it back around
and ending this interview on a more
wholesome note I'm I mean this from the
bottom of my heart huge congratulations
on birth rebirth this is something else
thank you to everybody out there keep an
eye out for the movie and for more
interviews right here from Sundance